I have loved beating Abby since I was
about four years old the movie came out
the year I was born in 1990 and I just
fell in love with bells she was this
feisty young woman who spoke her mind
and had all of these ambitions and was
incredibly independent and wanted to see
the world and was so smart and I loved
how she had this relationship with Beast
where they were just total
that to me just seemed like such a
dynamic and interesting kind of
relationship that I'd never seen before
in a fairy tale
I was just enamored with the whole thing
I was just so in love it was so funny
and so romantic but in a way that I
don't know for me it didn't feel
contrived in the same way that I think
perhaps other fairy tales have in a
sense that they beast and Belle really
dislike each other at the beginning and
they they really don't get on and then
they form this friendship and then they
fall in love and that there was just
something so beautiful about that to me
and I've just loved it ever since as a
child you love Disney but as an adult
you still love Disney because it sort of
connects you with that childlike feeling
that everything is going to be okay
and there's there's hope in the world
and it just sort of for me it just gives
me this sense of like ah everything's
fine everything's fine so to get to be
in you know playing Bell and to get
specially live in the world is you know
it's just amazing I was very excited
yeah and he's a huge challenge turning a
you know a 2d cartoon into a into a sort
of 3d human story I guess and it's also
a great story is a great character you
know it's one of the great characters
from from fairy tales really and I was
very excited my wife is very excited my
kids are very excited so yeah the music
for it is is sensational and you know
one of the great things about the
animated film was the you know blend of
romance and and
sort of classic fairytale telling as
well as a bit of humor and fun and and
that's something I think you know we've
really tried to retain and this is the
sort of you know the romantic side but
also a bit of the silliness you know I
hope that we will do justice to you know
the the love that people have for the
animated film but you know that people
felt that we've you know that we've
taken it on moved it on a bit brought
something fresh to it put a few new
songs to it I hope they like those and
yeah I hope that you know it's you know
it becomes another classic really that
the families enjoy and that the kids
enjoy and get them sort of engaged with
the with the fairy tale again because it
is a great it is one of the great fairy
tales I think something that bill and I
were keen to serve bring out was this
sense of a sort of petulant spoiled
child and and the sense of kind of
entitled miss that that led to his
downfall really and and so that was
quite fun just to kind of work into this
this very short little montage almost
entirely through the medium of dance
which is not something I've done a huge
amount of before but that was really
really interesting to kind of introduce
that element and then see that you know
through thread it through the beasts
story and you know to see him curse not
just for you know having refused a rose
but actually first for all his other
traits that that he could be damned for
bill seems to be having the time of his
life he's the man who is perfect for the
job he's passionate about telling the
story and about honoring the work that
had already been accomplished in 1991 by
by the amazing team that created the
original beauty in the beast but also
bringing Bill's element and allowing and
Bill's have been allowed to answer a lot
of questions that weren't answered in
the original animation that we can now
do because we have a full film and a
live-action feature to do that so coming
on set and working with Bill every day
has been a total joy and I wish this was
a year-long job and not a three-month
one I don't think it's going to sink in
completely until I actually see
myself on the big screen singing those
songs on the horse with my sidekick
Lefou it's one of the most recognizable
villains in Disney history and I've been
privileged enough to be given the honor
of bringing him to life with with with
in a human form and so it's magical it's
very exciting I just hope people think
I've got enough hair on my chest
probably not I have not done much comedy
in my career not from the want of trying
and this was my chance to do it and he I
hadn't thought so much about how the the
interaction would work with Lefou and
then I met Josh and then I realized that
whatever I had in mind that was going to
be funny was only going to be emphasized
and made better by having the likes of
Josh in the scene with me and allowing
me to bounce off his timing and him
bouncing off my timing and I think you
probably see that there's a lot of we
like each other and we really have had
the best time it's been just a wonderful
experience on and off the screen and I
but I think on the screen I think you do
notice that you'll see that this this
timing and this this compatriot ISM we
have with each other started off the
screen and then and and so we've brought
it onto the screen and we've just had
the best time he's a very very funny man
he's a very happy man and he brought a
lot of light and warmth to to the film
set and also to the scenes I think what
he's done with Lefou is he's brought a
much more three-dimensional character to
Lefou somebody who has a heart who
thinks a little bit more but is
desperately
enamored by by Gaston and adores him in
a way and we've had a lot of fun playing
those those elements of his character
with mine
character with his I remember going to a
Theatre in South Florida and watching
Beauty and the Beast for the first time
I think it was in 1991 and the the
memory that I have other than the fact
that I was watching something completely
magical was be our guest ended and the
audience erupted into applause and that
was at that time a very unfamiliar
response to going to see a movie it was
much more you were much more likely to
see that in live theater and to elicit
that kind of response from an audience I
thought was pretty amazing and something
I definitely remember vividly it's
breathtaking I mean the it's funny
because every day we would come to set
the actors would look at each other and
say like this is insane the amount of
labor the amount of manpower that it
takes to create just a scene you know
like this or anything it's just it calls
upon every creative asset that you have
at your disposal and we had the the best
of the best working on this from hair
and makeup to the production to the set
designers to props everybody brought
their a-game and nobody left an ounce of
it behind I mean it's all on the screen
and people slaved away to make sure that
everything in the frame was beautiful
and unlike anything you've ever seen
before to be a part of a movie that is
so iconic for me and my own children now
is also it's a dream come true I get to
recreate many iconic moments and
hopefully provide audiences with new
iconic moments as well and while we're
paying respect to a classic I think in
many ways we're setting out to to create
a new class at the same time it really
was the FIR
modern Disney heroine Disney Princess
you know who doesn't want to be a
princess who doesn't really care about
finding the prince you know someone
who's more interested in books and
seeing the world and expect and kind of
figuring out who she is then in finding
a guy in getting marriage he happens to
do those things by the end but it's not
because that's that's her main interest
you know so that was really you know a
bit of a cultural leap certainly in the
world of children's stories you know and
I think that's what's so interesting now
is it's 25 years later and it's often
things that are slightly revolutionary
become you know you sort of lose a sense
of how groundbreaking they were because
they were so influential that they just
become part of the culture how do you
distinguish Bell again 25 years later in
a live-action way you know and I think
that was that was so so much a part of
the casting of Emma Watson you know
because I do think of all the actresses
her age of her generation she is the one
who sort of most closely defined with
women's issues you know her activism at
the UN but in general it's really become
her life's mission you know so it was
very exciting I you know remember
writing her a note and kind of pointing
out that you know choices that people
actors making their career sort of
become part of their own autobiography
you know and that this seemed to have
such a great fit in her life thought I
was hoping she was interested turned out
she was had been interested for years
had been developing her own version of
it and what was then so exciting when
she got on board was to work together
with her well I think obviously yes
there's a great relevance that Belle's
position you know there's a great
relevance in Bell and and the treatment
of Bell as a Disney heroine you know
somebody who is not so interested in
finding the prince you know more
interested in developing herself and
reading and figuring out what's going on
in the world you know but also I think
the the
the general theme is one that was
relevant then it was relevant when the
story is written in the 18th century and
it just keeps taking on new new
relevance I think for us today clearly a
reminder that not that we shouldn't be
being distracted by surface beauty and
and everything that dazzles and that
real beauty comes from within I think
you know we're living another moment
where I think that's that's a message
worth worth imparting especially to
children when bill is leaning over the
beast and says I love you finally I
think you really the challenge was again
in a human way to make you think these
two people there's nobody else for
either of them you know and what that
meant was it really was an exploration
of how when Belle is walking through
that town in that first scene how did
she get there and I'm not saying we
haven't stuff before that but as the
movie progresses you understand what it
is that led her and her father there and
also what it is that makes her feel like
such an outsider and the same with the
prints not just boy he was nasty that
one night but what turned him into that
man who deserved to be cursed you know
so those are kinds of things that we
feel in in the in the film and that's
what excited me about doing it well I
think it was my love of the animated
film I saw it in 1991 I was already
about 20s you know I know it means a lot
to be able to see it when they're a kid
but even at that age I just thought it
was the most beautiful and kind of
perfect movie question becomes why we
make something that's perfect you know
that's a whole other thing but I think
it was my love of that film
I think it's dramatically it's so
powerful you know and I think we all of
us feel like the beast at some point or
another you know so I think that's a way
that I certainly connected to it you
know and and the great kind of
resolution of it you know the fact that
he finds kind of the way to his his own
humanity I think it's such a beautiful
beautiful story
you